hey guys my name is Jess it is the sixth
of September and you're watching games
but news that my shirt has a cat on it
after being delayed to allow for more
development time Batman returned to
Arkham now has a new release date Warner
Brothers Interactive Entertainment has
announced that the previously delayed
returned to Arkham collection will
launch on October 21 for ps4 and Xbox
one the collection includes remastered
versions of Rocksteady's batman arkham
asylum batman arkham city and all
post-launch dlc the publisher also
showed off a video that compares the
original games to the remastered
versions which are running on Unreal
Engine 4 and being developed by virtuous
games it's just one more sleep until
Sony are expected to reveal the new
slimmer ps4 but if you just can't wait
someone has posted a teardown of the box
on YouTube originally we just had a
bunch of leaked images to tide us over
but now youtuber links tech has uploaded
videos showing the ps4 slim being
disassembled if you want to check out
how sony fit all those ps4 bits in such
a little package you can watch the
teardown in both regular and fast speed
in a story on gamespot for a more
official presentation tune into the
playstation meeting which is scheduled
for September 7 at three p.m. ET fingers
crossed we could also hear about the
more powerful ps4 near tomorrow if we're
lucky another PlayStation bits presented
in a small package p SVR is coming with
a free demo disc to get you kick started
on ignoring real world stuff virtual
reality the disc includes driveclub
PlayStation VR worlds rigs tumble via
battlezone a Valkyrie away with sky and
headmaster the SVR is out on october 13
at least that approach red aren't ready
to tell us more about cyberpunk 2077 but
they asked that lee building up the dev
team in a post on their forums said
approach said there are currently more
game developers working on cyberpunk
2077 than on the witcher 3 in its most
intensive month on top of that the
publisher had 60 open positions for the
team on august 30 many of which were
focused on creating vehicle based
gameplay right now cyberpunk is expected
to launch sometime
in 2017 and 20 21 we showed ahead to
game swat 4 stories on duke nukem 3d and
star wars the old republic and do join
me spend time tomorrow for all the big
news from the playstation conference and
everything else in that is